full of other people who might want to
vote
close that poll and we'll move to the
last
question
very crop most most able to use higher
rates of nitrogen
is but um
all right we've got about 11
folks voting thank you very much
and now
we will move into the presentation
portion of the
the class of the webcast
and i want to introduce i don't really
think he needs too much of an
introduction
dr marvin pritz who is the small fruit
specialist um at cornell university
he is also the horticulture department
chairman and um
has also this is his second webcast of
this serie series but nutrient
management and berry crops and
thank you everybody and marvin
take it from here
okay and thanks everyone for joining
this is great what a convenient way to
be in touch with everyone
so we want to talk about nutrient
management vary crops and of course our
challenge is
the
diversity of berry crops that we have
out there
and each one requires some specificity
in terms of its nutrient needs but what
we're going to do is try to focus on
some general principles instead and
probably one principle that cuts across
all these berry crops in terms of
nutrient management are
first
get a soil test prior to planting you've
all heard this before but that allows us
to adjust the ph and our nutrient levels
and then for perennial fruit crops once
the plants are growing in the ground a
leaf analysis is usually the best way to
fine tune your fertilization program
and if you followed the soil test
correctly and got the ph right
and got the nutrient levels right
at least for the first five or six years
you may not have to do anything
in terms of fertilizer application
except for maybe nitrogen
but hopefully if you've done it right
and put those nutrients into the soil
before you plant you can have that long
of a time before you have to go in and
start fine tuning and for most very
crops
you might be ready to replant by that
time anyway
so these are the two overriding
principles for all of it
what happens if you don't
follow that test
and then you find out later oh my soil
ph is too low and i have to add some
lime and where to get those plants
growing well you end up with kind of a
mess because you're putting lime over
top of the planting and it doesn't
really work its way into the ground very
well
and it blows around and it's always best
to do that before you plant so you don't
end up trying to apply lime after the
plants are in the ground
so soil testing is real good
and then once the plants are growing we
can take leaves from those plants in the
middle of summer
after things are sort of stabilized
and look at the nutrients in those
leaves and we can tell whether they're
in the adequate range and if they're not
we can make a recommendation on how to
make that adjustment
and both of these tests it can be done
at cornell they can be done through
private labs
but the point is
using the nutrient analysis after the
plants underground is the best way we
can tell
what to do with your plants and give
recommendations
these standard fuller nutrient ranges
are
good only if the soil ph is in the right
range
if the soil ph is off then these values
all become off and it doesn't do any
good to play around with
potassium or calcium or boron
if the basic problem is the ph is too
high or too low
so if you know your ph is in the right
range then rely on the leaf analysis for
modifications
and each of those leaf analyses are
they're specific for different crops so
the blueberry one will be different than
the strawberry one will be different
than a raspberry one
what i want to talk about though are
some of the specific nutrient
requirements uh for in this case
blueberries we'll start off with
blueberries because i probably got a lot
of questions about that and indeed one
of the questions i asked
uh earlier was what's the most uh common
problem across the country with
blueberries and the answer that most of
you got was the ph being too high
so the first thing and the most
important thing in growing blueberries
is test the soil ph and make sure it's
you bring it down to about 4.5
that's pretty low for most crops
and
that usually it's going to take some
sulfur
and incorporate it into the soil and
letting that sulfur work for several
months before the site will be suitable
for blueberries once in a while you'll
find a site
particularly maybe down where sandy is
on long island where the soils are
already naturally
low in and
ph you can plant blueberries directly
into that but most
soils you have to apply some sulfur to
get that to happen
blueberries are very slow growing it
takes several years before they reach
maturity we figure about eight years
from the time you plant by the time
they're really full grown
they have some adaptations to these low
ph
low nutrient soils and if indeed if
you're walking through the woods and out
hiking around you will find blueberries
in sites that tend to have
acidic sandy soils usually sometimes
it's wet because they can grow there
and
one of the adaptations that blueberries
have
is that the roots have an association
with endomycorrhizal fungi and these
fungi actually colonize the fine roots
of blueberry
and the hyphae grow out into the soil
and aid in phosphorous and nitrogen
uptake
that's not all plants have
endomycorrhizal fungi in fact just a few
do and the iricase family the
blueberries belong to is one that has
this association that allows them to
tolerate
soils that tend not to have a lot of
phosphorus
and where a lot of the nitrogen is in
the ammonium form as opposed to the
nitrate form
so in your garden where you have fairly
high ph and the soils are warm you don't
have a lot of water out there
the most of the nitrogen gets converted
by the soil bacteria into the nitrate
form that plants can readily take up
you can fertilize your garden plants
with ammonium sources of fertilizer but
the bacteria convert it to nitrate and
then the plants take it up
blueberries have the unique ability to
take up the ammonium ion directly
which makes them really suitable for low
ph wetter cooler soils where the
predominant form of nitrogen is the
ammonium ion anyway
blueberries can also tolerate very high
levels of manganese
because manganese availability goes up a
lot when the soil ph drops
so if plants didn't have the ability to
tolerate that when you lower the ph
in some soils the manganese would go so
high that would be toxic to the plant
but blueberries have the ability to
sequester that
manganese and vacuoles and allow plants
to tolerate relatively high levels
and the other thing that blueberries can
do is they can tolerate low levels of
calcium
and in fact high levels of calcium is
pretty detrimental to blueberries they
do not do well where the calcium in the
soil is over say
2 000
pounds per acre and a lot of soils have
calcium that high i've seen soils where
the ph is low the cat but the calcium
levels are high
and the blueberries just don't do well
even though the ph is low that calcium
just doesn't help the plants for some
reason
this is a blueberry roots grown in
nitrate nitrogen and ammonium nitrogen
and you can see that
the nitrate form of nitrogen
makes the roots sort of
die it causes necrosis they do not like
the nitrate form and nitrogen whereas
the ammonium form of nitrogen they can
do just fine
interestingly if you did this with a
tomato or a pepper or any other
strawberry it would just be the opposite
the ammonium
force-fed plants would have black roots
and nitrate force-fed plants would be
just fine
blueberries are different
the other thing is that high levels of
nitrogen fertilizers are detrimental to
the endomycorrhizal fungi and hence hurt
the blueberry plant so you don't want to
fertilize with too much nitrogen on
blueberries because it hurts the plants
and the fungal association
another thing that hurts the plants is
too much chloride
and if you fertilize with potassium
chloride or murieta potash
you may be applying too much chloride so
on blueberry plants we recommend if you
have to apply potassium to apply
potassium sulfate
that's a lot safer to use than potassium
chloride around blueberries more
expensive but it's safer to use
so how do we manage blueberries so i put
this all together well we pick a site
with adequate pore space in the soil
select a site with low calcium
ideally less than 1800 pounds per acre
of calcium
high organic matter is really important
for blueberries they don't do well when
the organic matter is low
the lower the ph
usually the better and you can lower
that with sulfur until you get down
around 4.5
under low nutrient condition under low
ph conditions sometimes
magnesium becomes unavailable so
sometimes you have to apply supplemental
magnesium in order
to compensate for the lower ph
but rarely any others
usually in your pre plant soil tests
you know you might not have to ever
apply phosphorus because blueberries are
really good at sequestering phosphorus
such as endomycorrhizal fungi
the organic matter
that you want to have is you know the
more the better uh you can grow
blueberries on mux soils but ideally if
you have you know four to six percent
that would be good it also helps to
buffer against that ph requirement
so in a say a sandy soil with very
little organic matter you've got to be
right about 4.5 ph
on a sandy soil with a lot of organic
matter you can cheat a little bit you
might not have to go much below five
and so it just provides a a buffer for
that
and then
mulching with sawdust and wood chips to
maintain the organic matter and moisture
in the soil
when you fertilize blueberries
we recommend ammonium sulfate or urea
as opposed to other sources of
fertilizer that might contain nitrates
because again the nitrates are toxic to
the blueberry roots but ammonium sulfate
is perfect blueberries really like that
and you apply increasing amounts as a
plant ages
up to about
65 pounds per acre so
none the first year maybe 10 pounds the
next year per acre and then 20 30 40 all
the way up until you have about 65-70
pounds on a bush that might be seven or
eight years old
workout michigan has found that uptake
is much more efficient if you split the
application between bloom
and then six weeks later we used to
recommend putting all the nitrogen down
in april
but now we've found that it's much more
efficient to put it on probably in may
when they first bloom and then six weeks
later the problem with putting it down
in april was that the roots were not
active at that time and a lot of that
nitrogen was leaching before the roots
had a chance to take it up
so you need to wait until the roots are
warm
and then put it on a split application
also if you are using lots of mulch you
may have to increase the rate above that
65 pounds per acre to compensate
for the the mulch which tends to tie up
some of the nitrogen
here's a blueberry plant on the left
hand side you can see a plant with
adequate nitrogen and one over here with
inadequate you just look at the plant
just not nearly as green
and that's the symptoms of too low
nitrogen
this is magnesium deficiency and it's
fairly common in new york and the reason
for that is as a ph drops the
availability of magnesium also drops and
sometimes you can get in a situation
where yeah you got to have the ph low
but it also makes the magnesium
unavailable
and you may have to add some epsom salts
which is magnesium sulfate to build that
back up
and this is a symptom that you might get
when magnesium is low it's pretty
distinctive they call it sort of a
christmas tree pattern where you get red
colors between the veins and the veins
themselves stay
green
so that's real characteristic of
magnesium deficiency
and essentially what's going on within
the plant is the plant isn't able to
make chlorophyll at that level it needs
so the chlorophyll disappears there
isn't
there isn't as much of that and the
other pigments in the leaf start to show
up so you almost get the fall colors
maybe in the middle of summer showing up
because there's not enough chlorophyll
to mask the other anthocyanins
having a high ph
is the most common problem across the
country with blueberries
and the symptom of high ph is what we
call iron chlorosis
and this is
similar to what you saw with magnesium
deficiency except in this case it's iron
deficiency the leaves turn yellow
instead of red and again it has to do
with the pigments that are manufactured
and are expressed when the iron isn't
available
now interestingly enough
iron is one of the most common elements
in the earth's crust there's usually
lots of iron in the soil
the plant just isn't able to take it up
if the ph is too high
so you could add all the iron you want
to the soil but if the ph is too high
the plants are still going to be yellow
so two things you can do one is you can
spray
iron chelate on the leaves and sort of
foliar feed some iron and that will
green up the plants but that's only
temporary the solution to this problem
is a reduction in the soil ph so once
you lower the ph then the iron can
become in its active form and be taken
into the plant and used to manufacture
chlorophyll and other pigments that will
turn the leaves green again
another deficiency that we sometimes see
on blueberries particularly in sandy
soils is potassium
and again it creates a distinctive
symptom of this marginal burning it
looks like maybe the plants didn't get
watered and they dried out
and kind of that's what's happening
physiologically potassium is used to
help transport water through the plant
without potassium you don't have stomata
open and closing properly and you get
this burning
so if the potassium is low even though
you have adequate irrigation adequate
water you still might get this symptom
and i've seen this
i'm not so much in new york but i have
seen it in new jersey
but it's just something to watch out for
boron is a nutrient is relatively
commonly deficient in our soils in the
northeast and we see symptoms of boron
deficiency
a lot
and this is a
boron deficient blueberry plant
and
the grower thought this was winter
injury and indeed it looks very much
like winter injury we couldn't find any
pathogen on there it wasn't a canker
but it assumed it was winter injury even
though
the winters weren't that cold and
anyway bottom line is we did foliar
analysis boron tested out really low
and they applied a couple of pounds of
boron per acre and the problem went away
that's what it looks like on blueberry
we'll see in a few minutes some more
distinctive symptoms on strawberry
this is a healthy
blueberry filled what you like to see
grass between the rose straw mulch
and
vigorously growing plants
let's shift to strawberries for a minute
completely different plant not a woody
plant it's a herbaceous perennial
and it has a target ph of about 6 to 6.5
for making adjustments so for
strawberries growers aren't adding
sulfur to the soil they're generally
adding lime to bring the ph up a little
bit so it's in the adequate range
now strawberries are grown as either
annuals or perennials depending on what
part of the country you're from some
parts of the country you know people are
doing both
some people in new york are playing
around with annual strawberry production
and in practice some growers apply up to
400 pounds per acre of actual nitrogen
sprouted over the season but
data show that strawberry plants can
only use about 100 pounds
that they can take up so
in many annual systems 300 pounds is
just being wasted just being washed
through the soil profile and into the
groundwater
strawberries are very inefficient at
sequestering nitrogen the root systems
are somewhat shallow they're not very
extensive
and so you have to really spoon feed
strawberries nitrogen and you can't
expect them to take a lot of it out of
the soil
we grow strawberries in new york mostly
as perennials and
most of the growth of a strawberry in
our system occurs in early spring right
after we take the mulch off
and that's when carbon and nitrogen can
be limiting because the plants have been
under the mulch all winter long they've
they've used up all their carbon
just during the process of respiration
the nitrogen was used up last spring and
fall
and now they're deficient in both you
take the mulch off and they need to put
on this really fast growth spurt
these are some data
of strawberries
in the planning year planting them in
july you can see how the strawberry
plant grows kind of slowly it slows down
in the fall then we go through the
winter it loses some biomass during the
winter and the next spring it just
really takes off
push of growth at that time
so
logic would have it that well we ought
to be fertilizing our strawberries right
about here because that's right before
the big growth spurt and the plants need
a lot of nitrogen and
carbohydrate then to sustain itself
during this rapid growth spurt when it's
fruiting
but in actual aldi we've done studies
that show that those spring nitrogen
rates
make the fruit really soft
and increases our botrytis incidence we
did this for three years in a row and
every year we got the same results
anything more than about 30 pounds of
actual nitrogen per acre really softened
the fruit
so
if spring's kind of out because it
softens the fruit you know when when
should we fertilize strawberries
and the answer seems to be
immediately after harvest in july so you
wait until that fruit comes off then
put down some of your fertilizer
but we don't want to put it all down
then because strawberries aren't
efficient at taking up nitrogen from the
soil so we put maybe
two-thirds of it on after harvest
and then another
third of it on in early september
prior to flower blood formation that
seems to be the best timing
the roots are active they're taking it
up
and you
spoon feed them a little bit during that
time
we also have done some research to show
that fall
foliar fertilization helps strawberries
as well it seems to increase the
nitrogen reserves just before the plant
goes into the winter
if you put fall fuller applications on
during the summer it stimulates
vegetative growth and the plants grow
more but it doesn't result in more
yields
it seems like if you wait until after
growth is over
and then you put the fall folder
fertilization on like october early
october the strawberry plant takes up
that nitrogen
but it's not going to grow anymore
because it's too cold and the daylight
is short and that nitrogen actually goes
into the reserve pools of nitrogen and
then is available for the following
spring
we found that five pounds of foliar
urea actually nitrogen as full urea in
the fall gives us as big of a yolk kick
as maybe 30 pounds the following spring
so it's a very efficient time to put on
a foliar spray
these are some data
sort of hot off the press from a study
that we did on
fertilizing strawberries
on this axis let's see
this axis here we have increasing rates
of fertilizer so we grew the plants with
increasing rates of fertilizer and then
here we looked at how much nitrogen was
in the plant and i mean no surprise we
fertilize more
and we get more fertilizer in the plant
more nitrogen in the plant
but with just a little bit of fall
fertilizer as well fuller fertilizer we
can increase the amount of nitrogen
plant quite a bit
by just putting on a couple of
applications in october
trade-off you make when you do that is
that you actually decrease your
carbohydrate this number this is total
non-structural carbohydrate so as you
increase your nitrogen
your carbohydrate levels go down and
particularly when we increase nitrogen
from fall foliar fertilizer this is a
good way of getting nitrogen to the
plant it decreases your carbohydrates
now that's not a problem as long as you
have adequate carbohydrate but if you
don't have enough carbohydrate you can
actually see your yields decreasing
so in this graph here
we've increased our nitrogen without
fall foliar application as we increased
our nitrogen our yields go up the
following year and that's what we would
expect
but
if we
also increase nitrogen we fall
foliar feed we can get to the point we
get so much nitrogen in the plant that
our yields no longer keep going up but
they actually fall back down and that's
because we're above
the optimal amount for the plant and
we're starting to deplete our
carbohydrates to the point where the
plant can't
sustain itself during that spring flush
so down here we have just sort of put it
all together looking at the total amount
of nitrogen in the plant
going into the fall and looking at the
yield the following spring and we can
see that there is an optimal point
and it's you can exceed that
with high fertilizer rates
in a growing year coupled with fall
foliar fertilizer so you want to do too
much
but if you're moderately fertilized
in the growing season and then add a
little bit of fall fertilizer you can be
up in this range here which is good for
yield
here's a graph showing
yields with fall
fertilizer this is
no fall foliar fertilizer and five
pounds of fall
fuller your fertilizer and you can see
our yields jump quite a bit almost to
the same level that's where we put 30
pounds on in the springtime
so this is what i guess six times more
efficient and the other thing is with
spring nitrogen we're getting softer
fruit
so
we want to avoid the spring if we can
and if we want to if we don't think the
plants have adequate nitrogen
a fall foliar application seems to be
the best
so the goal of nitrogen fertilization in
strawberries is to boost those nitrogen
reserves so it has them available for
flower production and early spring
growth so late summer soil applications
are good
fall foliar applications are really good
spring nitrogen
boosts vegetative growth a lot the
plants really grow a lot when you
fertilize in the spring
but it doesn't have a big impact on
yield and it seems to soften the fruit
and then the summer foliar applications
also promotes vegetative growth doesn't
seem to translate into any yield
increase the following year
so here's that
picture i showed earlier about
strawberries ammonium forms of nitrogen
and you can see the roots are black so
this is just the opposite with
blueberries nitrate forms roots are just
fine mixture both somewhere in between
so if you force fetum
ammonium this is what happens that
doesn't mean you can't use ammonium
sources of fertilizer it's just that the
ammonium
fertilizers in the soil get converted by
the bacteria
into the nitrate form that the plant can
take up so go ahead and you can use
ammonium sources of fertilizer the only
time you really want to do that is if
you fumigated the soil
and you killed the bacteria so there was
nothing to convert the ammonium
fertilizer to the nitrate then you might
cause some toxicity
but in normal soils that haven't been
fumigated
you can use ammonium sources because
they're generally cheaper than nitrogen
now let's look at some deficiency
symptoms in strawberries so you can
maybe learn to recognize
what these plants might look like when
they're short of certain nutrients now
again ideally with growers you would
never want to get to the state where you
see visible symptoms of deficiency you
would want to do a leaf analysis
regularly every two or three years so
you could head off any deficiency once
you see visible symptoms then you know
you're having an impact on yields
you want to head that off by monitoring
plenty of time to the head
so here's a
nitrogen deficiency the leaves sort of
turn red this is a field of strawberries
you can see those red leaves this would
be late july
early august way too early for leaves to
be turning red on their own and that is
because this field was not fertilized
for a couple of years
software deficiency it's something that
we
don't generally see in the northeast
because we got lots of acid rain and our
acid rain contains lots of sulfur
and so the plants just every time it
rains they get fertilized with sulfur so
we tend not to see deficiency symptoms
of sulfur
but if we did this is what it would look
like
sulfur is a component of a lot of amino
acids and proteins
and nitrogen is part of amino acids so
we don't have sulfur this nitrogen can't
be converted into amino acids and the
leaves are yellow instead of nice and
dark green
okay potassium deficiency i mentioned we
see this in blueberries we sometimes see
this in strawberries as well
particularly where we have sandier soils
and the first thing you see with
potassium diffusion is a little bit of
browning around the
bottom of this leaflet here
and sometimes you can see some burning
on the margins of the leaves and they
also get this funny color a little bit
dark
mottled throughout the leaf
from potassium look at another
picture of this up close so you can see
the little bit of burning
along the edge of the leaf you can see a
little bit of
necrosis here where the leaflets come
and then you can see this little bit
darker color on the leaf than what looks
normal
so that is potassium deficiency
often with potassium deficiency you see
this on the older leaves first the same
with nitrogen you see it on the older
leaves first
and the reason for that is is that
potassium and nitrogen are very mobile
in the plant and they tend to be
mobilized from the older leaves into the
new growth so the new growth is a big
sink
everything moves there the sugar moves
there the photosynthetic the nutrients
all move to the new growth it leaves the
older leaves without any nutrient
because the nitrogen
shot off to the sink and the potassium
left and went to the growing point
the older leaves show these symptoms
this is you're actually in the field
looking at potassium deficiency and you
can see the marginal burning very
typical of any plant with potassium
deficiency you see the marginal burning
because potassium is so important for
water uptake and movement through the
plant
phosphorus deficiency this is what it
would look like i can't say i've ever
really seen phosphorus deficiency in the
field
our soils
in new york tend to have lots of
phosphorus at least historically growers
have used manure and that has lots of
phosphorus and
we just tend not to see a lot of it and
again you can test for it
and see if it's getting low
pre-plant phosphorus applications
usually take care of everything you
might need for the rest of the life of
your planting so it's not something that
we ever would generally ever recommend
growers do is go out and apply
phosphorus fertilizer to an established
field
and even if we did phosphorus is not
very mobile
so it would take a couple of years
before it ever worked its way down into
the root zone anyway
so
do a good job pre-plant and you don't
have to worry about phosphorus ever
again
phosphorus you get that reddish color is
fairly characteristic of phosphorus
deficiency
now calcium deficiency that's an
interesting one calcium is also very
important for
movement of water in the plant
and
calcium is transported through the
water
it's dissolved in the water and it's
moved through the transpiration stream
it's not really actively moved from cell
to cell like a lot of the other
nutrients are it moves up through the
water
and through the plant and if you have
conditions that do not favor movement of
water in the plant you sometimes will
get calcium deficiency symptoms usually
at the extremities because the water
isn't getting out there so on this plant
here you see this browning at the tip
and the leaf isn't unfolding properly
brown tip here brown tip here brown tip
here
this is the extremity of the plant the
water is not moving through the plant
and you get that brown tip it's
analogous to blossom and drought of
tomato exactly the same thing is
happening except here's the strawberry
so to prevent calcium deficiency it's
usually not well i need to apply lime or
more calcium to the soil that's usually
not the solution the solution is usually
and make sure the water the plant is
well irrigated
if you have situations where you let it
get really dry and then you water lots
and to get really dry again you're
likely to see these symptoms develop
so here is another extremity
this is
a growing tip
and it's already starting to turn brown
from the lack of calcium
and again a runner tip you see the brown
at the end of the runner and you see the
brown leaf here
so you see it in the extremities
so um laura asked a question about how
much reduction in yield
uh the fill would be seen i'm not
exactly sure what field so maybe you
could indicate what nutrient we were
talking about and i can give you some
sense of that marvin i it was the
nitrogen one i was just wondering
if you see something like that that's
that profound
what could you tell the grower like how
much yield might he be losing
yeah if and it feels like you saw there
without it being fertilized for a couple
of years i wouldn't be surprised if you
could lose
close to you could be down about 50
percent over what you might normally
have with adequate fertilization
nitrogen is a really important nutrient
for you know lots of things but you know
plant growth and fruit development
without that you don't get the flower
bud initiation that you need
and that's
determines the number of fruits you're
going to have the following year
okay magnesium deficiency we saw this in
blueberries remember this is the one
with a christmas tree like shape
in the leaf and here
we still we also see
intervenal
coloring
but in this case here unlike the
blueberry doesn't turn red it just sort
of turns a dark funky color
and then if it's real severe
you'll get brown between the veins
so again
that intervenal necrosis or coloring is
often typical of magnesium deficiency
usually you find that when the soil ph
is getting too low
and in the case of magnesium it's not as
mobile in the plant so you tend to see
this on the newer leaves first as
opposed to the older leaves
so that's one way you can look at a
plant kind of help narrow down what the
deficiency might be
mobile nutrients you see the deficiency
first and overleaves immobile nutrients
you see it first in younger leaves so
magnesium is not as mobile it's part of
the chlorophyll molecule and it doesn't
move around as much it's a big molecule
kind of stays in place so you see that
in the
younger leaves first
marvin i just i'm sorry to interrupt i
just want to bring to your attention i
think your voice might be dropping a
little bit in volume and
um maybe just getting a little closer to
the mic might help okay i'll try to do
better
so this is iron deficiency iron is also
a component of chlorophyll synthesis
chlorophyll is a big molecule doesn't
move
so you see the deficiencies
in the younger leaves first so you
notice in this plant here the older
leaves still look reasonably green but
the center leaves the younger leaves
that are coming out are the ones that
are yellow
this is a strawberry root and it's a
healthy root and you can see lots of
nice white roots lots of root hairs it's
growing really well now the next slide
i'm going to show you is boron
deficiency
boron is a nutrient that's responsible
for auxin synthesis and if you remember
from
your biology class
auxin was responsible for cell
elongation
so when you don't have cell elongation
you have you know the meristems abort
and you end up with stubby roots so the
next slide is a picture of a strawberry
grown in a low boron solution and the
root hair is just sort of abort and
you're left with these stubby roots
and with stubby roots you don't get a
very good uptake of other nutrients so
i've seen time and time again
strawberry fields and raspberry fields
too where the leaf analysis comes back
lots of things are low
but boron is also low
and
often times not always but oftentimes if
you correct that boron problem with a
couple of pounds of actual boron per
acre and get those roots to grow again
the other deficiencies kind of correct
themselves because now the plant can
take up those nutrients that it couldn't
otherwise because there's a decent root
system under it
so i look for boron
frequently when i'm looking at leaf
analysis one of the first things i look
at and indeed if you look at all the
leaves that were ever sent to cornell
in the leaf analysis
boron is the one that's most commonly
deficient in our leaf analyses that we
analyze here
some leaf symptoms of boron deficiency
asymmetrical leaves
and then this is one kind of interesting
too this is
you know the fruit obviously looks like
maybe tarnish plant bug or maybe poor
pollination or frost injury
but it's boron deficiency and again
these little
seeds on the strawberry are called akins
they secrete auxin that causes the
receptacle tissue underneath it to
expand
so as long as those little akins are all
in gear all pollinated and all secreting
oxen you get a really nice berry
but if the plant can't make oxen
then these berries can't expand very
well so you get all these deformed
berries again characteristic of severe
boron deficiency
now the challenge with boron is that you
can also apply too much it's one of
those that doesn't have a very wide
range of where it's either you know
deficient or toxic so you've got to make
sure you don't put on too much or you'll
get the burning
the burning in this case
it looks very much like potassium
deficiency but it's actually boron
toxicity
and this is also you know zinc too much
zinc can cause
you know problems as well as too little
and that's why the leaf analysis is so
important
just a couple of things on raspberries
and blackberries we're not going to go
through the whole feel like we did with
blueberries and strawberries but we have
the summer bearing types
and just some thoughts on nitrogen there
too much nitrogen can lead to winter
injury
on summer bearing types because they
have to get through the winter and so
can fertilizing too late therefore with
summer bearing raspberries we fertilize
in the spring
if you fertilize too late or use too
much you'll get winter injury and we can
see winter injury right here it's killed
the canes
the new primocanes are growing just fine
but the old canes aren't doing so well
now fall bearing raspberry since we
usually mow those down every year
it's you know too much nitrogen usually
isn't an issue and raspberries have a
pretty extensive root system and they're
really good efficient at taking up
nitrogen so
they can handle a lot more nitrogen and
they grow
more vigorously with more nitrogen and
they can handle it so there we fertilize
in the spring and we can fertilize in
the summer
at and combine the rates a little bit
higher because you don't have to worry
about going too late
or putting on too much because we're
just going to cut the canes anyway
we've done a little bit of work on
foliar feeding of raspberries
and we put on these foliar sprays and we
monitored the uptake of the foliar spray
into the plant we used
n15 which is sort of a tracer it's not
radioactive it's a stable isotope of
nitrogen but you can spray it on and
watch it move into the plant
and we looked at various factors to see
if any factors might aid in the uptake
of the urea that was labeled
and we looked at
surfactants
we looked at you know time of day
we looked at the ph as a solution we
looked at plants that were stressed or
not because a lot of the companies that
sell these products say well you know
you didn't put them on at the right time
or didn't have the right surfactant and
stuff like that this is our control
we were getting his you know our
standard treatment just mixing it with
water and spraying on was giving us
almost 50 percent of the nitrogen being
absorbed almost anything else we do
either didn't make a difference or
actually
reduce the uptake
so
i don't think there's anything magic if
you want to use it about half of it goes
on
we did the same thing
looking at a potassium analog in this
case we looked at rubidium which is a
periodic chart it's the same valence as
potassium behaves the same way
sprayed to rubidium on looked at uptake
again almost the same thing our standard
treatment was pretty much as good as we
could get
maybe putting on early in the morning
was a little bit better but for the most
part it didn't make a difference
the problem with these foliar
applications though is that even though
we get 50 uptake you can only put on
about five pounds of actual urea per
acre at any one time or else you get
toxicity to the leaf if the plant's only
taking up 50 of that
that's two and a half pounds and truth
of the matter is not all that you spray
on hits the plant some of it just goes
off into the air it never really touches
a plant so
in actuality you're probably only really
getting into the plant one or one and a
half pounds of actual nitrogen with
every time you spray
so it's not a very efficient way of
applying nitrogen you almost have to
spray every day to get give the plant
the nitrogen it needs from foliar
applications and our data show that it
doesn't make any difference anyway when
it's sprayed during the growing season
the only time we're seeing the
difference is when it's sprayed late in
the fall
to contribute to those nitrogen reserves
so to wrap everything up
pre-plan amendments are important
bases on soil test recommendations from
a reputable lab
use leaf analysis to fine-tune your
fertilization and establish plantings
and generally not always but generally
restrict nitrogen applications to the
spring
although evidence exists of building
reserve nitrogen late fall can be
helpful if carbohydrate status is
adequate
so
all right
thank you thank you marvin does anybody
have any questions and i apologize if
there's some problem with the audio for
some people um it sounded really good to
me but that doesn't mean that everyone
else is having good reception and i
certainly would appreciate feedback
about how the quality of the
presentation
and
so this is your opportunity to ask
marvin some questions about the
the presentation does anybody have any
questions
if not i'm going to move into the final
oh hold on
stephanie has a question stephanie
would you i think you have a microphone
now if you have one or you could type
the question in the chat box
okay i'm not hearing from stephanie you
might want to
type right down at the bottom of the
chat box stephanie or if you have a
microphone i you are unable to to ask
the question right now
so molly just asked a question about
were the last comments
about foliar feeding for strawberries or
raspberries the data i showed you an
uptake was for raspberries
the data i showed you on the actual
yield response for fall foliar
fertilization was for strawberries but
strawberries and raspberries
are fairly close related and most of the
time when people do these studies they
find that strawberries and raspberries
generally spawn the same way
so i wouldn't be surprised
if we did those same studies that we did
on strawberries with fall foliar
applications we did that to
raspberries whether we would see the
same response ylang chung here in the
department has done those
studies on grapes and apples and he's
found the exact same thing that late
fall
foliary applications increase nitrogen
reserves and improve yields the
following year provided that
carbohydrate levels are not too low
i don't see why raspberries would be any
different
um marvin there was a question from dan
welch about differences in nutrients for
day neutral strawberries
okay yeah so day neutral strawberries
are quite different than the regular
perennial strawberries they have very
shallow root systems
they allocate only about
10 of their growth to roots and that's
pretty low compared to like a raspberry
where it's 50 or more so these really
shallow roots they don't go out very far
so with they neutral strawberries you
really do have to
spoon feed those nitrogen almost all
season long
and we recommend
about one pound
of actual nitrogen a day for day neutral
strawberries during the growing season
now you don't have to fertilize them
every day unless you're set up to do
that you can put a pound of nitrogen
through the irrigation system
once a day but we don't recommend going
more than about seven days before you do
apply
that nitrogen so if you're gonna do it
weekly
you know seven pounds every week would
be equivalent one pound a day but they
need that much to get them through and
if you add that up over the entire
season they're using more nitrogen than
a regular strawberry it probably
shouldn't say they're using more but
they just
need a lot of nitrogen around because
their roots aren't really very good at
sequestering what's there so you spoon
feed them
and uh about one pound a day the other
nutrients potassium
phosphorus and all
that's the same you know if you put
enough in the ground before you plant
then you don't have to worry about that
and they're they're grown mostly as
annuals anyway so that's not a big deal
with daniel's but the nitrogen is
and we don't have to worry for most part
about
fall folder applications because most
people are not overwintering their day
neutrals anyway but if they would it
would probably have the same response as
a june bearing
craig thank you very much for answering
that one question
these series have all been recorded and
this one will also be available it was
recorded today
and we will open them up to the general
public shortly
so you can
you know you will be able to get them or
and recommend them to growers if you
would like to do that
i want to thank
dr pritz for taking the time today and
earlier in the session and also greg
loeb and courtney weber because they
were the other speakers it was a little
bit different presentation style and i
really appreciate them
uh
you know taking the time to learn how to
do it and everything i also want to
thank all of you for joining us it
really wouldn't be any good if we didn't
have anybody listening and asking
questions
and i do want to ask if you folks
wouldn't mind just taking one quick exit
poll
and i'll deliver this now
just give us a little feedback
this is an um multiple answer so you'll
just
read the questions as they're numbered
and then answer them in the boxes just
click on the box you don't have to hit a
submit or anything
and we will be able to have that data
to help us evaluate the sessions and
then also
maybe move forward with some other
webcast training
and then unless you have any other
questions for marvin after this poll is
done
that's it thank you very much
pretty much everybody that i expected
to weigh in has weighed in and i
appreciate that
and if anything else to add please go
ahead otherwise have a great day
you